we had Luke I think a lot of us are
pretty irritated and Michael is just
fists and started coming at me Luke Luke
I'm here for Hannah and don't you ever
forget it
so grab your glasses it's time for roses
and rose hey is your name Luke not if
lauren zima hi you guys we are here to
recap episode whatever the heck we're on
of Hannah Brown season of The
Bachelorette and in the words of Connor
who I will impersonate now because we
didn't see much of him in this episode
ready to go things went down brah oh man
like people had one-on-ones and people
had like group dates and it was like
who's really here for the right reasons
Connor
so everybody we have 15 guys left 15 of
you guys left and now it's time to leave
the mansion cheers to going to
[Music]
I mean look I love an East Coast moment
a little Hamptons a little boat a little
wine a little sunshine I'm here for it
but man oh man DuBose got his cheer for
Newport Rhode Island you would have
thought Chris had said Newport Pluto
we're going to a planet that's not even
a planet anymore you guys are the first
to explore the next realm of space
report Rhode Island
so cheers every time they cheer because
they cheered for new pool and then they
cheered for this okay looking hotel and
just Cheers
but you know I appreciate the enthusiasm
Wow I'm tired you guys I'm really tired
I'm crazy last several days it's work
especially and I don't know why I'm
acting like this is coffee but I don't
know it I'm just maybe I'm just pushing
myself into a deep sleep please drink
responsibly Jed gets the one-on-one and
we really like Jed so far don't we so I
had my eyes glued to this date because a
couple of times every season they just
have a normal date no helicopters no hot
tubs have we gotten a hot tub Issy's
[Music]
unless I'm wrong have we correct me in
the comments if I'm wrong but cheers -
no hot maybe it's because Ana had such a
bad hot tub experience with Colton on
her one-on-one that she was like
triggering triggering but I'd like to
see hot tub but anyway this is one of
those normal days you know where people
are walking through a city and exploring
and be-bopping around a farmers market
and saying hello to some locals who
they'll never see again
normal truly and Hanna even told Jed
quote I don't think I could just do this
date with anyone and they were talking
about how and this is the most normal
date possible I don't think I could do
this daily
so Jed said it was a real date and it's
been amazing to just have like a real
date so it felt big to me that Hanna
said that she could only have a normal
date experience with Jed interesting
okay I gotta call this out though drink
for the weird halo top guy showing up
again
the halo top guy he was the guy who
showed up on the women tell all for
Colton season is just so weird that
Hannah didn't acknowledge that we'd seen
this guy in the show before ring for
that whole slow zoom in on the logo and
this date with Jed is like the longest
date ever drink for every activity
they're doing because now they're doing
the sports it's not like a fun roller
derby sport it's like a real sport only
they're in a play basketball oh I'm
awake I'm awake
Thank You Hannah B this is for you you
know big jerseys I'm like could I get a
custom perfectly tailored red powerhouse
female pantsuit moment and I know you
guys have some of you men calling out
how much I wear red I'm sorry it's
always been my favorite color I think I
wouldn't it okay Boston Celtics and
they're so excited because it's the
Boston Celtics and I'm like could we get
settling D on on a date maybe I'm just
dreamed casting my dates not because I
don't know these basketball players are
so I do want to give one of them a
shout-out because he did have a good
conversation with Hannah I'm giving her
some solid advice on what to look for in
a guy somebody makes you laugh somebody
to be yourself with but like why we're
never gonna see this guy again I don't
care Celine Dion
never say my heart will go on to jet and
Hana on that basketball court instead of
them playing basketball then part three
of Hana and Jed's Odyssey of a day two
ends they go to get dinner and Jen makes
a big confession to Hana he tells her
straight up that he first went on the
show at least in part because he thought
it would be a good platform for his
music career you've asked for nothing
but the truth this entire time my first
thought was you know this is like a huge
platform I'm aghast has anyone ever done
this in the history of the show just
owned up hey I came on here kind of
looking for some fame I'm starting to
feel like I kind of falling for you what
did you guys think of it smarted you had
to do or did he plant a seed of doubt
for Hana by acknowledging it at all so
ahead ahead oh my god would that be
their celebrity name Hana and Jed it was
a really bad one don't get that going
that's not a good one Jed tells Hana I'm
starting to feel like I'm falling for
you do you guys believe Jed
[Music]
next up it's a group date of rugby
sports but I gotta say I'm okay with
this one and shameless plug we were on
this date exclusively yes I was there in
the report and I have to admit I did
enjoy it but again I wasn't like no pod
but great clam chowder Luke is wavering
back and forth for me between he's just
kind of a mature guys got to figure out
and like oh my gosh this guy's like a
jerk I can't figure it out
Peter seems to have come to some kind of
truce with Luke because Luke is jacking
him up for this rugby game drink every
time Luke screams I am
Le'Veon roses now my go-to how many
songs get my brain right star is born
and will never die his Pluto star planet
why did I say Newport pollute oh I was
so weird
I can't lift my shoulder guys get looked
at so kevin has some kind of shoulder
injury which we didn't see drink every
time the cameras miss the big moment
this episode but they are like cutting
his shirt off it's that serious and he's
getting in an ambulance what I did also
love about this sport though the guys
were that I black stuff it was like
running down her face it looks like
Lauren Conrad crying her mascara off on
the hills classic then drink again
because we didn't see this big moment
where Luke pee apparently need or choked
out or tackled or something Luke s we
missed it where were the cameras where
the cameras I'm sorry but we need to see
this stuff it is a reality show
[Music]
we can't control himself we're gonna
animal this becomes the driving drama
for the rest of the episode so I really
wish we've been able to see it ourselves
I'm upset like pee doing again now cut
to the cocktail party and Hannah pulls
loopy aside to talk about the ham versus
loukas moment on the rugby field but you
know he's heard it's like you cussing me
out and like clicks his fist and started
coming at me Lucas on your side of
things but then everybody talks to
Hannah about loopy including the man who
makes his opinions known mic loopy has
100% said Tomas face I think I was
telling Mike then I'm starting to fall
out of love her do you guys believe Mike
here's the thing as much as I like Mike
and think he keeps it real after him
saying that ham was trying to get a pity
rose to Hannah last week I don't know
about Mike also because I interviewed
cam on et live where we have live guests
every Tuesday morning at 10:00 a.m.
Pacific to talk about the night's
episode plug watch the interview guys I
had a little bit of a redemption moment
with cam he was more grounded than the
show might have made him look and cam
said that he never said he wanted a
quote pity rose so I don't know it
becomes he said he said but I don't know
if Luke said this he seems pretty
obsessed with Hannah so I'm not sure I
believe it who do you believe Mike I've
got 14 friends in this house Garrett
does some math that is rough he says to
Luke I've got 14 friends in this house
and you could seriously hurt one today
I'm gonna let you know that I'm not okay
with that I have 14 friends in this
house and I'm upset because you could
have hurt one of them and they're 15
guys left
so that means Luke is one of those 14
which is Garrett saying he's friends
with Luke but is Garrett saying Luke
could have hurt himself and also there
weren't 14 or 15 guys on that group date
so 14 or 15 guys didn't have the
potential to get hurt Garrett's a golf
pro
stick to the yardage is anything in golf
yardage JC doesn't know it either
I should ask someone else I know you
don't really know go for it with wine I
don't mind it then you guys things go
south for Luke like souther than Alabama
south or than Georgia south of and South
America south or than Pluto where is
Pluto how does space work this is health
it's I don't know his face directions
oh god I'm over here critiquing Garrett
while he was on the ground he's
accustomed me and he's coming up to me
with clenched fists so Luke is trying to
tell the rugby story of what happened
between him and Luke s and first he says
he can't really remember I don't
remember how it happened and then he
starts to remember details I think I had
the ball I'm pretty sure Isis disarmed
him and then the guys call him out for
not remembering and then he says he's
starting to remember now that you're
telling me that I remember now
oh not a good look Luke lMNO Luke man no
I got a stop alphabetizing canvas gone
I'm done I'm sorry I'm done and then the
guys have had enough and they just walk
away and drink for every guy that just
walks away drink responsibly
here's the thing Luke I get that you're
trying to be who you are and be there
for Hannah and I get that this reality
show situation is probably wild but if
everyone else is against you that's a
bad sign
like that might be a sign it's not
you're just fighting with one person
it's everybody else's disagreeing with
what you're saying did you guys see
Luke's Instagram you say he's trying to
be a better man that the show's teaching
him a lot then Garrett had bad math but
he has a good moment with Hannah and he
gets the rose and I was glad to see this
because Garrett was actually kind of an
earlier pic of mine like he's also from
Alabama
he seems like Hanna's type but he got a
little quiet and Hannah even said I have
been just trying to get you to just the
ice wimpy what do you think could
Garrett pull into the lead or is it too
late let me know you are a very special
girl and I feel like honestly that's one
of the luckiest guys in the world to be
here
and Hannah and Peter of course by the
way are continuing to have smooth
sailing
ooh soaring whatever I just have still
mourning the loss of that sailing date I
wanted to get that sailing date but then
the show is the gift that keeps on
giving and it gives me a boat it's not a
sailboat
it's a tugboat it's a lobster boat
it's a crabbing boat it's a boat from
Discovery Channel's hit reality show
Deadliest Catch I don't know but it's a
boat and at this point I just want to
tell everyone that I my phone died and
so I couldn't take no it's not my phone
anymore so I took notes on these posters
so this is a new method and we're gonna
try it okay and whoa Hannah is waiting
for Tyler to show up for their
one-on-one and she's getting so
emotional struggling with my emotions
today crying about the Luke situation
and saying that her feelings for Luke
are the strongest at this point feelings
for him probably the strongest Wow
that really goes to show you what that
initial and important connection between
her and Lucas but it also makes me think
is it just about the physical chemistry
because she and Tyler have some
conversations on the state that are
pretty solid and have we really seen
Hannah and Luke have solid conversations
and again they could end up on the
editing room floor oh I like being able
to do that goodbye notes Tyler shows up
and Hannah tells him she's upset and he
just says he's gonna be there for her
I'm here and oh my gosh I kind of fell
for Tyler after this speech you guys
you're getting down there's a reason why
you're going through all this right now
there's no doubt in my mind that this is
all kind of make you better at the other
day
Connor talks like this and Tyler like
dogs
there's got like a nice like deep like
grizzly just that's what I want to give
the mayonnaise to you at the end of this
you know not too intense but it is
southern I got I don't think they're the
same anymore they're different to me now
after that speech Tyler did Tyler pull
ahead for you on this date what do you
think I already said that Wow flying
through these two okay and then we're at
the cocktail party and sometimes I just
love these little moments on the show
there walking into like a mansion or
something and you hear someone go whoa
Lyons
I'm like lions like is this mansion
belong to one of those really rich
people who has like exotic pets and it's
like no it's a lion statue and did
somebody really say that like Walla
Lions about like a carving that was a
whole note
so Peter oh my gosh at the cocktail
party Peter grabs Hanna first and what a
move
Peter Peter plane eater makes cheers to
this Peter asks Hannah if you wanted to
be my girlfriend
to be his girlfriend it's so simple yet
so revolutionary so basic yet so bold so
youthful yet so much sure Peter I am
here for it
cheers to Peter all around has anyone
ever done that in the history of the
show test me on my knowledge you guys I
don't remember but let me know in the
comments below if you do
I loved this and I've had this
realization about Peter and I want you
guys to tell me what you think if Peter
doesn't end up with Hannah
I think Peter could be the ultimate
here's why Nick Viall posted this photo
with him and Peter I have been
consistently saying that Peter it
reminds me of Ben and then I looked at
all that together and I think that Peter
is the matzo biological love child of
Nick Viall
and Ben Higgins and that would make him
the ultimate bachelor I mean think about
Nick's cred he's been on the show so
many times cause drama shed tears Ben
pure of heart
handsome just a good guy but also did
crazy things like was the first one to
say I love you to women oh my god it
could be everything we've wanted it more
Andy is a real job he's a pilot he wears
those Nick Vale sweaters but he says
those Ben Higgins phrases like I want to
be intentional in this relationship I've
ever liked being like intentional like
direct and relationships very important
oh my god what do you guys think I don't
know I mean now he has Peters girlfriend
so they could end up together and I
don't want to sound where do they end up
together and I wish them the best and
all the happiness because Peter seems
great but if not beautiful bachelor you
know I wanted a Peter before I didn't
get him is this what was promised okay
about this not used to this but all
right then we have to take ourselves out
of the magic that is Peter and go back
to Luke vs Luke the double whammy we
didn't want the argument we didn't see
coming and we literally didn't see it it
wasn't filmed when they collided okay
Luke had said earlier in the episode
that he didn't remember the fight but he
really seems to now because he's really
walking us through it I have my eyes
over at the game and I step over him and
Mike is being the man
and calling Luke out pissed off with the
fact that the actions of a few days ago
is still lingering and at one point he
calls him something like a millennial
some people believe that's what you
acting like that's what you are I
couldn't understand what he sings you
guys understand it leave in the comments
below but you did but no matter what
it's even something then we get this
moment we've seen in the trailer where
he's calling Luke P an evil liar
manipulative psychopath that's who you
are and Luke pulls out his phone is the
definition of psychopath
do show the definition of psychopath
crap I forgot what my background was
anyway drink for every time I'm not sure
if something has ever happened on the
show before on this episode have we ever
seen a contestant to hold a phone truly
like a cellphone like that I've found
something here that I do believe that
you are here for a reason and then oh my
god Luke see he tells the other guys yes
Luke s isn't here for the wrong reasons
and he says that he's gonna go tell me
out of the truth I'm shocked
is he spiraling is he just boiling under
the surface I'm baffled and then oh my
god Luke P is shady as hell the last
person I want to talk about right now is
blue Tess he that I got alone my voice
he then I'm gonna vocal cord he then
goes to Hanna and eyes he came up to me
um like asking me to put in a good word
for him deal when a really Luke he had
promised to go tell the truth and the
truth was that he had been lying about
Luke as his intentions
[Applause]
mmm
I haven't happen this mad about somebody
in a while what did you guys think of
this go off in the comments below so you
know the guys all saw this go down and
I'm like Hannah asked the group you know
we're going into this Luke set versus
luke set thing asked the group because
they all saw Luke Pete admit that he was
not being real about Lucas's intention
keep a real girl Dani Hannah's kind of
eavesdropping and we end on this
cliffhanger where it's Luke and Luke
sitting down with Hannah and I got to
say when she went and grabbed both the
Luke's I wonder one of the guys to stand
up and just say Hannah we heard what was
said clear the air I don't like to live
in this he said he said for too long why
is anything on camera roll the tape just
say what was said okay
shameless plugs go too easy online calm
for our interviews from the group date
I'm on cameo if you want a cameo I won't
yell in your cameo I will sing you a
song truly ask me for a song that you
want write some ideas for lyrics for me
I love doing it and our last shameless
plug we have coming in now everybody a
very well-dressed man he has brought us
grey suit looks but today he is rocking
navy and a man bun JC everybody JC is of
course here for more than cleanup and to
do more than just look handsome guys JC
is here for his first ever shameless
flag you guys bachelor nation fans I
also edit on this special show on ET
style called unfiltered and Becca Tilly
bachelor alum is on the next episode so
make sure to check it out we have a lot
of bathroom behind-the-scenes love it
unfiltered it's this great show that ET
style does where a celebrity takes off
their makeup and kind of tears down
their walls which we love on The
Bachelor tells their secrets and stories
and gives you guys insight so JC edits
it back Attili on the upcoming episode
go check it out
and guys we are here every Tuesday with
roses in rows a Tuesday mornings on et
live at 10 a.m. Pacific we always have a
guest last week it was cam mm-hmm and
I'm just gonna finish this wine in honor
of my good friend an upstanding man JC
he's no loopy babe
I'll get from the side I just only do
this shot today because this is a mess